Right, it's happening.
I put up a video last week talking about
how it was difficult to make friends in Italy.
You're an adult and you move to a new place
and it's just.
It's just hard to make friends.
Well, I propose that we should do a meet up.
It was actually a lot of interest,
I got DMS, I had comments.
So I think we should do this.
And I am all about safety,
so I have actually set up a Telegram group.
And to enter into this group
you're gonna have to DM me and I will send you the link.
Your Telegram profile
should definitely have a profile picture
so I can kinda see who you are.
Cause I'm not gonna accept people who have no name
and no profile picture.
Just people feel safe going out
meeting strangers on the internet, you know?
I am going to be organising a meet up here in Polonia
and hopefully in the future
I will be able to organise some in other Italian cities
and even event
see how these meet UPS go.
So if you're interested in making friends
here in Bologna, DM me
and I will send you the link to the Telegram group.
I'm so excited to do this.
Anyone who's struggling to make friends,
you are so welcome into the group.
I'm really looking forward to it.
So I'll see you very soon.